reykjavik c'est une bonne nouvelle les
messageries conviviale une manière
disons pudique de désigne le minitel
érotico porno les messageries roses ça
marche et même trop bien
dans ce domaine les dérapages sont
faciles vous vous en doutez et c'est
justement ce qui inquiète le ministère
des ptt
il vient de publier un communiqué dans
lequel il s'émeut et orrit du
détournement abusive de ce mini tél aux
fins de prostitution ou d'atteinte aux
bonnes moeurs et compte saisir à ce
sujet la commission du suivi télématique
c'est vrai que certains ne se contentent
pas de télé maths et en prolongeant
leurs petits dialogues par des
rencontres que crespo tu veux ou tu veux
pas l'élu de ton corps bien sûr c'est
tellement facile maintenant 36 15 sur un
téléphone un code et c'est la porte
ouverte à tous les fantasmes
mais quand ceux ci sont un peu spéciaux
la morale d'en prendre un coup
telle la découverte d'un réseau de
prostitution d'adolescents dans le
sud-ouest la création de messagerie
bénéficie d'un vide juridique total
quiconque dialogue est assurée de
l'anonymat le plus complet
et puis kelman 77 centimes toutes les 45
secondes dont 48 tombe dans l'escarcelle
du serveur
il faut pas que cet instrument des
changes soit détournée je crois que
c'est très rarement le cas il ya
effectivement toujours quelques brebis
galeuses qui ce qui s'immisce dans le
troupeau il ya toujours quelques gênes
un petit peu trop aguichante qui
cherchent à tarzan musclé mais article
rien ne force
tarzan à répondre aux appels de jane et
d'autre part il faudra aussi que la dgt
qui assure un petit peu la promotion du
minitel ne se fasse pas à sa façon par
son annuaire et par le modèle de
relation d'un certain nombre de données
monique ce nom un peu barbare pour
désigner des dons de codes qu'elle ne se
fasse pas un petit peu l'instrument de
promotion de messagerie qui sont-elles
purement et simplement pornographiques
je pense par exemple à sexuelle ou
externes côté ptt on rejette toute
responsabilité ni complice ni espion il
n'est pas question d'espionner il est
auto plus question si nous sommes
informés par des usagers ou par la
presse d'usagé délictueux des moyens de
télécommunication nos directeurs
régionaux saisirons la justice en
adressant une lettre au procureur de la
république du lieu où est installé le
serveur au rythme de deux à trois cents
personnes qui dialogue par jour et par
messagerie et devant l'absence de
responsables d'éditeurs ou serveur il
semblerait que l'onirisme télématique
est encore de belles heures devant lui
alors